>> I WANT TO SAY WHAT TONIGHT IS
REALLY ALL ABOUT.
THIS IS FROM MY HEART.
FOR ALL OF YOU BRAVE PATRIOTS
AND ALL OF YOU PEOPLE THAT HAVE
SACRIFICED SO MUCH FOR THE LOVE
OF COUNTRY AND FOR OUR LIBERTIES
AND FOR OUR FREEDOMS AND FOR THE
GIFTS THAT GOD GAVE US OF FREE
STATE THAT WE LIVE IN.
AND I BELIEVE THIS IS THE
GREATEST COUNTRY GOD GAVE MAN.
THIS NIGHT IS FOR ALL OF YOU.
AND YOU MADE ALL OF THAT HAPPEN.
>> Steve: LOOK AT THAT.
LAST NIGHT, HE'S ON THE STAGE.
THIS MORNING, HE'S ON THE STAGE.
SEAN HANNITY, GOOD MORNING.
>> SAME STAGE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU GUYS.
>> Steve: WE HAD THE MARCHING
BAND FOR YOU.
>> THIS REALLY IS GETTING OUT OF
CONTROL.
THE GOOD NEWS IS IT WASN'T RIGHT
OUTSIDE OF MY HOTEL ROOM AS IT
HAS IN THE PAST.
>> Steve: YOUR HOTEL ROOM LOOKS
LIKE A GUITAR!
>> Ainsley: USUALLY WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE TO SPEAK IN FRONT OF 5,000
PEOPLE, YOU PREPARE A SPEECH,
RIGHT?
>> Steve: ABOUT FIVE MINUTES
BEFORE HE STARTED.
>> Ainsley: THIS IS WHAT HE DID.
>> Steve: ANYBODY HAVE A PEN?
>> Ainsley: DOES ANYBODY HAVE A
PEN?
STEVE HAD ONE AND WROTE DOWN
FIVE WORDS, THAT'S IT, WENT UP
THERE AND YOU DELIVERED SOME BAD
NEWS LAST NIGHT.
>> I DID DELIVER -- I STARTED
OUT, I'M SORRY, I'VE BEEN HERE
AT FOX THE LONGEST SO THEY GAVE
ME THIS HORRIBLE TASK.
I HAD TO ANNOUNCE TO THIS
MASSIVE CROWD, IT'S WHAT, FOUR
LAYERS UP TOP, RIGHT.
I SAID YEAH, SORRY TO HAVE TO
INFORM YOU NANCY PELOSI HAS BEEN
FIRED.
>> Brian: WHAT WAS THE REACTION?
>> THEY WERE VERY UPSET.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE CRYING.
>> Ainsley: YOU GOT A STANDING
OVATION FOR THAT ONE.
>> YOU DIDN'T GET THE STANDING
OVATION.
MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE, THOUGH,
WE SAW THAT YESTERDAY.
>> Brian: IT'S INTERESTING,
STENY HOYER SAID I'M GOING TO
MOVE OVER, TOO.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT HE
WOULD BE LIKE AS A LEADER?
>> RADICAL HARDCORE LEFTIST.
AS LEFT AS NANCY PELOSI WAS.
HE WILL BE MORE LEFT.
I'VE ALWAYS SAID, NANCY PELOSI
TO ME NEVER WAS THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE.
NANCY PELOSI TO ME WAS SPEAKER
IN NAME ONLY.
IT WAS A.O.C., IT WAS THE SQUAD,
THE NEW GREEN DEAL SOCIALISTS
THAT REALLY CONTROLLED THE
AGENDA.
>> Steve: RIGHT.
GLAD YOU MENTIONED THAT.
SO WHAT ROLE WILL THEY HAVE IN
THE UPCOMING HOUSE?
>> I THINK THEY'LL HAVE A LOT OF
POWER.
I THINK THE PARTY HAS SWUNG HARD
LEFT AND THEY'RE GOING TO STAY
THERE AND JOE BIDEN IS RIGHT
THERE WITH THEM.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED THE QUESTION,
I'M NOT SURE IF YOUR SON PETER
ASKED IT BUT SOMEBODY ASKED THE
QUESTION, WHAT WILL YOU DO
DIFFERENTLY?
THE ANSWER WAS NOTHING.
WE CAN EXPECT MORE OF THE SAME.
MORE INFLATION, HIGHER GAS
PRICES.
WAIT UNTIL ALL OF YOU AT HOME,
WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE YOUR HEATING
BILLS THIS WINTER.
WAIT --
>> Brian: THEY'RE SEEING IT.
IT'S TRIPLED.
IN SOME CASES IT'S TRIPLED.
>> 45% ON AVERAGE IS WHAT WE'RE
EXPECTING.
ALL OF NEW ENGLAND IS ON ONE
GRID, NEW HAMPSHIRE,
MASSACHUSETTS, MAINE, ETC.,
THEY'RE NOT SURE IF THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE BLACKOUTS THIS
WINTER ON THE GRID.
>> Brian: THEY'RE RUNNING OUT OF
DIESEL, TOO.
>> EVERYBODY WILL BE FREEZING ON
TOP OF THE 45% INCREASE, JUST TO
HEAT YOUR HOME.
>> Steve: YOU'LL HAVE TO GO
OUTSIDE AND GET INTO YOUR
ELECTRIC CAR IF YOU WANT TO STAY
WARM.
>> IF YOU WANT THAT ELECTRIC
CAR, IT'S 22 GRAND MORE THAN A
GAS POWERED CAR AND YOU HAVE TO
PILLAGE MOTHER EARTH AND TAKE
OUT THE NICKEL AND THE COBALT
AND THE MAGANESE AND YOU HAVE TO
POWER THE ELECTRIC CAR AND IF
THEY LET YOU IN CALIFORNIA ONLY
DURING CERTAIN HOURS.
YOU HAVE TO POWER IT WITH A GRID
THAT'S 90% FOSSIL FUEL.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> Steve: YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING,
YOU'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR YEARS
ON YOUR SHOW.
YOU DELIGHTED THE CROWD LAST
NIGHT WHEN YOU BROUGHT OUT A BAG
OF FOOTBALLS AND YOU THREW THEM
OUT BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN YOU DO
THAT AT THE END OF THE SHOW AND
GOING TO COMMERCIALS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE LEFT WITH THOSE
SOUVENIRS THAT THEY WILL PUT
PROUDLY ON THEIR MANTLES?
>> WE WERE DURING THE SHOW LAST
NIGHT, WE HAD A BIG CROWD
OUTSIDE.
BY THE WAY, GOT TO GIVE PROPS TO
PETE, HIS WIFE, THEY PUT ALL
THIS TOGETHER.
AND EVERYBODY THAT WORKED ON
THIS.
EVEN GAVIN, GAVIN DID A GREAT
JOB.
>> Brian: EVEN GAVIN.
>> HE BRINGS IN THE MARCHING
BAND.
>> Ainsley: THERE'S PETE.
>> BY THE WAY, THANK YOU.
YOU DID A PHENOMENAL JOB LAST
NIGHT.
AND I THOUGHT THE COOLEST OUTFIT
OF THE NIGHT WAS YOURS WHEN
YOUED  -- YOU HAD A TUX AND YOU
OPENED IT UP AND IT WAS THE
AMERICAN FLAG.
THAT WAS IT.
NEVER FORGET IT.
>> NAILED IT ON YOUR SPEECH,
TOO.
>> Ainsley: WHERE DID YOU GET
THAT?
>> CUSTOM TAILORING.
CAN I HAVE IT?
THEY SAID NO.
I SAID, CAN YOU TRY HARDER?
>> Steve: MAYBE BECAUSE IT'S
WE'RE IN HOLLYWOOD BECAUSE YOUR
HAIR LOOKS HIGHER.
>> Pete: SOMEONE TOLD ME IN
BETWEEN PETER DOOCY AND STEVE
DOOCY.
I ASKED FOR THE ILLUSION AND
THEY GAVE IT TO ME.
>> Brian: LOT ABOUT HAIR LAST
NIGHT.
>> I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY
TIMES THAT PEOPLE SAID, IS YOUR
HAIR REAL?
PULL IT.
TAKE IT OUT.
>> Ainsley: WHAT DO THEY ALWAYS
SAY WHEN THEY SEE YOU IN PERSON?
>> YOU LOOK TALLER IN PERSON,
YOUNGER IN PERSON.
AND SKINNIER IN PERSON.
I'M LIKE SO I'M HEAVY, SHORT AND
OLD.
I DON'T WANT TO GET YELLED AT.
HEAVY, SHORT AND OLD ON TV.
I SAID THANKS A LOT, I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
>> Steve: THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR GETTING UP EARLY.
>> I LOVE YOU GUYS.
I LOVE "FOX & FRIENDS" WEEKEND
AND WHAT A SPECIAL NIGHT LAST
NIGHT WAS.
I WAS HONORED TO BE A PART OF
IT.
>> Brian: WHO'S ON YOUR SHOW
TONIGHT?
>> I DON'T KNOW YET.
I'M WORKING ON IT.
>> Ainsley: GO BACK INTO RADIO
AND DO TV.
>> I GOT RADIO.
>> Brian: KEVIN MCCARTHY, WHAT
KIND OF SPEAKER DO YOU THINK
HE'LL BE?
>> I THINK REPUBLICANS WILL FIND
A WAY TO UNITE.
I THINK THEY'LL FOLLOW THROUGH
ON THE COMMITMENTS TO AMERICA.
WE SAW THE INVESTIGATIONS THAT
WILL TAKE PLACE YESTERDAY.
F.B.I., D.O.J., ORIGINS OF COVID
AND I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO GO
REALLY HARD INTO THIS HUNTER
BIDEN AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, COMO
WAS VERY CLEAR, THIS IS ABOUT
JOE BIDEN IN THAT LAPTOP, HUNTER
BIDEN IMPLICATES HIS FATHER
NUMEROUS TIMES.
AND THIS COULD END UP BEING THE
BIGGEST PAY TO PLAY SCANDAL IN
HISTORY.
>> Brian: IS HE GOING TO BE OUT
THERE MORE NOW?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
DOUBT ABOUT IT.
HE'LL BE A KEY WITNESS IN THE
CASE.
>> Steve: WE'LL BE WATCHING AND
LISTENING.
>> GETTING RID OF ME NOW.
>> Ainsley: YOU CAN STAY.